So your app's now in the state that the saveProfile method
knows that when it's called, it should be passed data that
conforms to the fields to find in the profile form class,
which in practical terms means that the input data can include
display name and t-shirt size. If it includes anything else, those
fields will be ignored. However, our app wants to use the
email. And so we'll need to get the email and we'll
do that by getting the email of the logged in user.
This of course means the user must be logged in.
So next we need to update saveProfile to take a
user input argument and to throw an exception if the
user isn't logged in. In the saveProfile method you'll be
adding a user argument as the first argument. This means
that when the saveProfile method is called, the user will
be passed to it automatically. If the user isn't locked
in, then the user argument's going to be null. It's really
easy to get the user, all you have to do
is to add this argument to your endpoints method. So even
though the user gets passed in, there's no automatic check that
the user's logged in. So we need to do that check
ourselves. So you can add the code to check if
the user is null and if it is, to throw an
UnauthorizedException. We also need to update our code to use the
email and the user ID. We can get the email and
the user ID by calling methods on the
user. The user ID uniquely identifies the user, and
the email of course is their email which is going to be very handy when the app
wants to send emails to them. The method
for getting the user ID and the email are
fairly intuitive. Get email. Get user ID. Wouldn't
be too hard to guess those. We already have
the code for getting the display name out of the profile form. But what
if the user doesn't provide a display name? We can write code to set a
default display name based on their email.
The ConferenceAPI class already provides a function
extractDefaultDisplayNameFromEmail, which basically gets your name from
your email but leaves off the @domain part.
So for example, if your email is lemoncake@example.com
then the display name simply becomes lemoncake. The server's
pretty easy to just add the code to check
if the displayName is null, and if it is
to call this function, we already wrote the
function for you. Obviously, need to save all your
changes, then redeploy, and see what happens. Now, let's
see what happens when we try out our app
in the APIs Explorer. Just to be sure
you're not logged in, go to the APIs Explorer
in an incognito window in Chrome. Okay, let's
see. Save profile and execute. Oh, now, look. This
method requires you to be authenticated. You may
need to activate the Toggle Bar to authorize your
request using OAuth 2.0. So the API's Explorer
knows that we're not logged and that it requires
a user. So we have to activate it. The only thing our app's doing right now with
user information is getting their email. So it's
asking the user to give permission for the app
to get their email. Now, let's resubmit. Maybe
I'll add some properties. That's teeShirtSize small and we
execute. Now you see that the request went
through. The request, the display name is Knikki and
the t-shirt size is S, which is what
I input. And you'll see the response includes
the display name, the main email, the t-shirt
size, and the user ID. One thing to
notice about running your app on localhost is
that no matter what your real email is,
your email is going to be interpreted as
example@example.com. And if your API doesn't throw an exception,
if the user's not logged in, then the user's going to be set
to test@example.com. And you can if you like, run this again without
providing the display name. Let's execute it. And this time you see
in the response that the display name is inferred from the email.